hello and welcome to steampunks
GameSpot's new show where we look at
steam games of the past week and tell
you what's worth throwing down some
money for I'm Edmund Tran
so you probably noticed a bunch of steam
games that are going up that are not
flying under your radar including what
I'm of them tied to you definitely don't
need us to tell you about that but they
are some games that fly under the radar
every single week that are totally worth
playing that you might want to know
about and haven't heard about so that's
all we're gonna try and do for you
[Music]
hey guys it's edited from the future
turns out our mics were turned up a
little high for our very first episode
so apologies for blowing out your ears
occasionally bear with us on this one
because it sure won't happen again
thanks for watching and enjoy the show
so just what you play this week alrighty
sir the first game I played is something
that is causing a little bit of a buzz
in on this demas fear it's called ghost
of a tail and the best way to describe
it is its thief with a mouse it's
described as an action RPG by safe CG
who's the developer and the publisher
and it's absolutely gorgeous
you are probably looking at the mouse
right now who is probably the cutest
in-game Mouse I've ever seen it's
ridiculous I don't know Moss just came
out on Thursdays I reckon this little
guy is gonna give Moss Mouse a run for
his money it's ridiculous um also teeler
the mouse has basically working up in a
prison cell and his wife is gone missing
and he's trying to find her so basically
it's thief's functioning in the world of
like a bug's life like it's just
functioning on this tiny little level
and obviously you're a little mouse so
while this is not PG you're not really
levelling things like oh I'm gonna get
like super tough like you need to sneak
better you need to be able to run faster
so in the beginning areas you're
basically stealing Keys grabbing stools
to hoist yourself up to higher areas you
can grab keys you can also dress your
little mouse up in like pirate garb and
like all these different outfits and
it's bloody adorable it's just a really
clever little game it is a callback to
those old-school stealth games because
there's very little hand-holding
you absolutely need to figure out for
yourself like how to proceed okay well
you mentioned the thief and when I think
of thief because I love feat I think
give stuff like setting things on fire
and dousing flames with water instead of
manipulating your environment yeah to
give yourself an advantage is there any
of that and this you do have a candle
and Atlanta and can burn certain things
okay so in the beginning area you're
basically in jail for a long time and
then you get out into a more open area
where you're basically trading as you do
in most RPGs deciding to go off and do
quest poppy
for information so it's $25 so you're
hitting about a mid-range price there
but I think for the amount that they've
worked on it and the reception it's
gotten so far which is pretty damn
positive after got about 700 reviews at
this point if this does look like your
thing I don't think you'll be
disappointed
yeah I think I'm definitely going to
check this one out yeah well the first
of my games this week is not so cute but
it's pretty cool it's got a cool design
set its called Echoplex so this is a
first-person spatial puzzle game in the
vein of things like portal antechamber
and cube so the first thing that needs
to be said about this game is that its
presentation is slick as hell the design
is really minimalist and it's got a sort
of pharmaceutical look how strange
futuristic pharmaceutical look but it
has these really well-done full-motion
cutscenes that teases your quote-unquote
memories as you go through the game and
sort of presents an intriguing mystery
like piece by piece but game wise it's
unique mechanic is the existence of
echoes which you trigger after you've
been in a level for a certain amount of
time and these echoes will follow the
exact path that you take so as you can
imagine this is using a lot of different
puzzles that make you sort of run
through a level double back on yourself
stand in one place for a few seconds
while your ghost catches up with you and
then it will just execute a bunch of
things that you may have triggered
yourself now obviously when you have a
game with multiple copies of yourself
you really get into sort of unsettling
narrative Puteri big-time so if you
touch your echo in a stage you die you
have to restart it's got a really
accessible mechanic where every time you
fail and return to your starting room
there's a little like map of the level
that's slowly drawn on the wall of the
room in sort of like a permanent marker
as if your dude is making notes for
himself that's great it's got that you
know the the present-day stuff an
assassin's creed where it feels like
he's trapped in he's in a conspiracy
it's got that kind of like really
interesting vibe about it so yeah it's a
good brain teaser
although the difficulty in the puzzles
ramps up really really quickly and they
in the hour or so that I played I was
like breezing through this pretty easily
and I then I eventually got to a stage
with drones and drones introduced and
have gone
and they have a parking mechanism that's
really it's a bit tricky to judge where
they're gonna go and have they're gonna
shoot and since they can one-hit kill
you it can be really frustrating if you
don't click onto the solution
immediately so this one just came out of
early access phase it's 15 bucks on
Steam for PC and Mac alright well we
were in the future so uh let's go back
let's go to the future we're actually
going back to the 1700s on the
break-even very end of the 1700
there is a adventure game although I
hesitate to call an adventure game
because it is unlike anything of a
played called the council and the
council takes place in 1793 you you and
your mum actually who both have weirdly
unfortunate noses and the decision was
on that front you're part of this order
that also has George Washington in it
for some reason they reckon it's not
based on true events but it also they
seem to be suggesting it's like
conspiracy theory it's Illuminati type
it's a secret society golden order the
game opens with you and your mother
trying to escape some guy who's
threatening you and you managed to do
that and you get to make a decision
really early on whether you want to
trust her to handle the situation or
whether you want to handle it yourself
and that's a really good example of how
the rest of the game goes there are tons
of choices to make and they seem to have
really divergent paths based on what you
decide to do so a bunch of time passes
from that point and your mother has
she's basically a super spy she's like
way good at her job and you're like kind
of her lucky so she goes off to this
island it's very prestigious island
where she's been invited where George
Washington also rocks up and this
English Duchess and a guy who I'm pretty
sure represents the Vatican and your
mom's gone missing she's just gone oh so
some of the interesting things you can
do in this game is okay so you know when
you it is got a lot of RPG elements you
know when you saw an RPG you pick a
class right so say you only ever wanted
to be a talker like say you're the kind
of person who only
puts points into intimidation or
persuasion or charisma this is that game
every single thing that you can put
points into is related to talking or
related to knowledge yeah yeah so it's
like do you want to you get to pick but
if you want to be a detective who's
really good at picking up on signals and
seeing things in the environment or you
can be a diplomat who's just really good
at talking the talk and getting people
on side and making people like you or
you can be an occultist so that's a more
knowledge-based one where you just know
the ins and outs and you're able to not
so well it's like speak to people but
know what people are talking about and
when they're alluding to things that's
why straight knowledge yeah it is 1700
Street no that's right you can make
decisions based on the skills you've
earned by being one of those classes and
what I really love about this game is
that it keeps telling you when you can't
do something because you didn't pick
that skill oh okay
so it makes it it makes it really clear
to you that are if you'd pick this you'd
be able to do that but you can't so
you're gonna have to find another way
another interesting thing is every
character has immunities and
vulnerabilities when you talk to them so
for example the creepy are servants in
the mansion who wear giant marks on
their faces so you can't even see them
one of their vulnerabilities is
questioning so if you get into hod
questioning with the servants they'll
back off they're like oh my gosh I'm so
sorry yeah so you need to be clever
about what you do there are also a
couple of other things like
opportunities so you will have a timer
that will run down it's not any point in
a conversation a couple of glowing bits
will appear on the screen and there is
something there to investigate and if
you pick the right one it will be like
hey I noticed this interesting crest on
George Washington that has to do with my
mother or whatever it doesn't matter if
you have all the talents in the world if
you bought all of them by getting all
the skill points if you run out of
ability points you have to find a little
they kind of like potions like little
honey deposits that reinvigorate your
ability points otherwise you can't do
them anyway I do have a complaint in
that the movement is an absolute
nightmare dude
Ron Dalls along turning is a nightmare
his turning circle is like a tank
the
the voice acting is he don't miss but
it's just really impressive and the
things that trying are really great
right so this is just episode one as
well this is just episode one yeah so
this is an episodic game there's gonna
be five episodes in total and right now
it's gonna cost you $30 for all of them
and from what I've seen so far so damn
with it
alright well that game advanced genre in
many different ways but my second game
does not advance the genre in fact it
actually goes back in time to a period
where this genre was much simpler than
it was today and I'm talking about a
medieval a medieval is an only access
game that's just gone into steam and
it's a retro throwback 1990s
first-person shooter
this one's got a medieval fantasy theme
so basically all your enemies and demons
and the undead so it distinctly reeks of
games like Hexen and heretic it's
incredibly fast paced and very
old-school so if you like the pacing of
the doom reboot but hated its modern
modern-day affordances like takedowns
and all that kind of stuff then this
might be more up your alley if you
haven't already delved into it basically
what you go up against is tons of
enemies and a bunch of unique weapons to
take them down with so you have like
axes swords and you know I mean it's
been a while since we've seen like a lot
of fancy weapons in a fast-paced shooter
no regeneration so you'll need to find
and match pickups to both your health
and mana which is basically your ammo
there's some light level puzzling like
finding keys with doors and you know you
say do you need to pay attention to the
levels which are pretty big the controls
are very tight which is great because
you move really damn fast and the game
can get pretty damn hard so it's an
early access right now and I think there
are like three and I'm like a eventual
seven so yeah it's 20 bucks on Steam and
like I said if you like a reflex based
shooters give it a shot you can't really
go wrong
oh well that does have a steampunk so
this week I can find links to all the
games we mentioned today in the article
or in the YouTube description if you
think we missed a real gem in the past
week be sure to let us know on Twitter
I'm at Edmund Tran and I'm at just
Macdonald and also do keep in mind that
we'll be back same time next week and
you should let us know if the game
appears on Steam between now and then
that you think we absolutely should
cover in next week's show but until then
see you later
[Music]
[Music]